- [Narrator] In China's Huanglong Valley,
you can find 2.2 miles of
naturally formed hot springs.
Just follow the yellow, calcified trail.
These colorful ponds have
formed over 1,000 years
by geologic change, causing
the limestone to mold
and the crystal clear waters to overflow
into the series of pools below.
On either side of this natural wonder
are rugged mountains and forests.
From a distance, the cream
yellow rock of the hot springs
leaves through the forest, standing out
as a steamy oasis.
The color and shape result in the locals
calling the pools the Yellow Dragon.
Huanglong Valley is also home
to the Huanglong Monastery,
and one of its remaining temples
can be found at the top
of the pools' terraces.
For many years, the area
was under the threat
of industrialization,
but through local efforts
and being a UNESCO site, the Yellow Dragon
will be seen in its natural beauty
for generations to come.